[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFFREY JAGODA:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting webinars daily.
My name is Jeffrey
Jagoda, and today we
are going to be talking
about Chrome Enterprise
and keeping your business
safe in the cloud.
Thank you for joining me.
Throughout our presentation,
you can ask questions
anytime on our platform, and
we have googlers standing by
to answer them.
Now let's get started
into the presentation.
So the title of
this presentation
is "Keeping your Business
Safe in the Cloud,"
and I think you're here today
because a lot of businesses
face challenges as
they move to the cloud
and keeping their information
and their businesses secure.
And given the fact that
you're joining us today,
you probably have some
of these same concerns
for your business.
Since the advent
of the cloud, we've
helped to address many
of these concerns,
but there's a lot of
traditional security concerns
that you may have as you face
moving towards the cloud.
So we're going to be covering
Chrome Enterprise has
a very unique approach
to endpoint Security
and simplifies
device management,
and keeps your data safe
and your users protected.
[INAUDIBLE] There we go.
So I think we're all aware,
in today's environment,
that the threat of
sophisticated attacks
is constantly on the increase.
Overall, malware variants
have increased 88% since 2017,
and the attack vector
surfaces have increased.
Ransomware like WannaCry has
infected over 400,000 machines,
and 98% of victims were
Windows 7 computers.
And as Windows 7 is still
out in the environment,
they are still
vulnerable to ransomware.
And finally,
phishing attempts are
one of the most common ways
that infections find themselves
into organizations.
Through email, users are
deceived to click onto attacks
and put software
onto their computers
and unwillingly give
out information,
including their data and
username and passwords,
which can be a major security
concern for companies.
So let's also talk about
the material impact
it has on businesses
as they try to address
these vulnerabilities.
So year over year,
security companies
have new software offerings
out in the environment,
and companies are
increasingly buying software
to help protect
against these threats.
So the security market is
forecasted to increase about 9%
in the following
year, here, in 2019.
What the major concern, though,
is that the number of threats
is increasing by 27%.
So while there's an increase in
technology to help mitigate it,
it far exceeds--
the threats far exceed the
ability to mitigate them.
And so this is a
growing problem,
because the amount
that you spend
to protect your information
and protect your endpoints
may not correlate
to your ability
to actually mitigate those
risks and defend from them.
So as we see more traditional
security approaches broken,
there's a lot of
familiar threats
that are cataloged by security
companies and security
software, and then they're
implemented by your security
teams and organization's
IT administrators
to hopefully combat that
security threat that you
have in your environment.
The fact is, though, that
increasing the global security
budget shows a
genuine willingness
to address these
threats from companies.
But it doesn't mean
that it actually
decreases the
number of incidents
that organizations have.
And so the organizations
incrementally
funnel more and more time into
patchwork security systems,
endpoint protection, and
putting out spot fires,
but they don't have
a holistic approach
to fixing these issues.
And simply throwing money
at it doesn't actually
solve the problem, either.
And it's time to rethink
your endpoint strategy.
And this is something that
Google Chrome Enterprise
is available for you
to rethink that, right?
So let's talk about Chrome OS.
It's built with
security by design.
It was built like that when
the platform originally
started, and isn't like
your traditional endpoint
where usually you're layering
on third-party software
to protect it.
It's a completely
different mind shift
in your thinking on how
to protect your endpoint.
Trusted applications
is another way
to increase your security in
your environment and decrease
vulnerabilities.
By only publishing secured
applications and applications
that are approved
by the organization,
you reduce the threat
to your business
by having unknown applications
in your environment.
And finally, protection
against current threats.
And this goes back to,
like most organizations,
they have to update
their computer systems
and their software and
their endpoints constantly
to stay protected
against these threats.
To combat these, we often
deploy different OSes
or other embedded OSes to help
with these security factors
where malware and some
of these other things
aren't available by design.
But then you're still
left, as an administrator,
still combating these threats
with other third-party tools.
So now let's look at how
Chrome Enterprise has
a completely different
approach to how you
can keep your business safe.
Chrome Enterprise
devices and browser--
Chrome Browser-- are
secure by design.
They deter users from falling
hostage to harmful attacks.
In the event that
one does happen,
Chrome Enterprise has various
security tools built in
to mitigate those attacks and
lessen the ability that they
would have on your systems.
We have a series
of management tools
and a multifaceted ecosystem
of various products
to ensure that you stay safe
within your organization.
We also offer 24 by 7 support
to protect you and your assets,
including your people, your
data, and your customers.
So now let's talk and go
a little more in-depth
about the security by design
about Chrome OS and Chrome
devices.
So Chrome devices are built with
security from the ground-up.
And you can see, in the
representation of the chart
here, every Chromebook is
built with the same principles
in mind-- the firmware, the OS,
the applications, and the data.
And the applications
being Chrome OS
and other applications you
deploy in your environment.
So no matter what
hardware manufacturer
you pick, whether it's an
HP, a Samsung, an Acer,
or Google-made hardware
like this Pixelbook,
all these pieces are within
every single Chrome device
that you may purchase
as a customer.
They all work in
harmony together.
The firmware, the OS, and
the applications and the data
are all updated
through one update
through your Chrome OS update,
and they work in harmony
together.
And additionally, Google
works very closely
with the manufacturers
so there's no--
so only the hardware works
with Chrome OS that's
developed by the manufacturer.
So finally, let's talk
about data encryption.
It's a very popular
topic that comes up,
and in many traditional
environments,
enterprises are
left having to find
third-party tools to
encrypt their data not only
of their operating systems,
but of their user data as well.
Chrome OS, out of the box,
protects any user data
with encryption on the device.
There is a trusted
platform module,
which is a tamper-proof design,
that helps protect the user
data on the devices by
encrypting it as the users are
working within their session.
This tamper-proof system
was designed by Google,
and is implemented
by the OEMs, and is
available on every
single Chrome device.
And in fact, encryption is the
default on every Chrome device.
There is no way to have a Chrome
device that is not encrypted.
So let's talk a little bit
about preventing OS tampering.
And this is another
very unique thing
that Google's able to
do with Chrome OS that
enhances its security
beyond traditional OSes.
Verified boot is a manner in
which the Google hardware,
along with the
firmware and the OS,
is able to check against
the known image that
is made and provided
by Google that
is in that known stable state
as it was originally deployed.
So in this example here, if
the OS was to be tampered with,
it would not pass verified boot.
When it doesn't
pass verified boot,
the device is not
booting, and the data's
not available to users.
And at that point, the device
either needs to be reimaged,
or wiped so it could be
restored to factory defaults.
So let's also talk
about Chrome OS
and how it actually reduces
your data footprint.
Chrome OS devices are
unique in which data is not
traditionally stored on an OS.
While it does have
a file system,
it is not traditional
like a traditional file
system that can be accessed
by applications and users.
The file system is
essentially locked down
and is not
accessible, and is not
accessible by the application.
So it really reduces
the attack vector
that malicious applications
would have on the device.
Additionally, by reducing the
actual data-- the user data
and your company data-- on the
device, if the device is lost,
you can be assured that company
data isn't on the device,
because the data's
used in the cloud
and is not stored
locally on the device.
But we can also know that if the
data is stored on the device,
it is in an encrypted partition,
and they use a partition.
And finally, a feature that's
very popular in Chrome OS
is what's called
ephemeral mode, which
means every time the user
enters and exits their session,
any local data, any cached
data is wiped every single time
so they have a
clean user session,
and no data is left behind.
There's no data footprint.
So regularly
patching and updating
is a very common administrative
task of computer systems,
and Chrome has a unique update
method for its Chrome devices.
So every six weeks, Google
produces a new version
of Chrome OS, and it is
available for Chrome OS devices
to be updated to.
It is in best practice to keep
your Chrome OS up-to-date using
automatic updates, and
additionally, security patches
are delivered every two
to three weeks as well.
We offer what's known as
Dev, Beta, and Stable channel
to our customers so
they can actually
be testing Chrome OS software
ahead of its actual release
to stable branch.
This gives security
organizations,
IT administrators,
and application owners
the ability to test
their applications
before it's launched to stable.
So if there are
security issues that
need to be mitigated
with an application,
an IT team is able to
discover those early on,
before Chrome is updated.
And finally, the most unique
thing about Chrome updates
is how quickly they
happen in the background.
Patching is really a seamless
process where patches
happen in the background.
It's one patch for
your Chrome OS update,
and that includes your
firmware, your hardware, the OS,
and the application.
And that one update
happens in the background,
and is nothing more
than a 6-second reboot,
or a close of the lid
and reopening the prompt.
So Google also offers
a lot of other services
outside of the
Chromebook that also
help deter employee negligence.
So I think we all know,
in a corporate office,
there is extracurricular
internet browsing,
and that can introduce
vulnerabilities
into your environment-- users
clicking on phishing emails
or visiting websites outside
their corporate allow list.
And what Google offers
is Google Safe Browsing.
Safe Browsing prompts
users about malicious sites
before they navigate to them.
And this is the power
of Google keeping
a huge database
of known websites
that are malicious
or ransom in nature,
and prevent users
from going to them,
and will prompt users
if they go to them.
And from the
administrative side,
from an enterprise
management side,
you have the ability to
block users going to them.
And this is a Google
service that you
can layer on top of
your Chrome OS device
to make sure any of
that extra browsing
doesn't affect your
infrastructure.
So now let's talk about some of
the various application stores
that Google manages
to keep malicious apps
off your devices,
and can present users
with different aspects
and features of Chrome.
So there's many different
types of applications
that you can deploy
on Chrome OS.
On Chrome OS, you can use
our Google Play Store.
This is the Android
market that you're
very similar to using
on your Android device,
and you can deploy Android
applications to your Chrome OS
device.
You can also access the Chrome
browser, which is a popular way
to access web applications.
Finally, the Chrome Web Store--
these are extensions
that you can
install onto your Chrome browser
and your Chrome OS device.
And most recently is running
native Linux applications.
Linux can run within a container
on your Chrome OS device,
and you can deploy Linux
applications to them.
So let's talk about sandboxing.
Sandboxing is something that
is very unique to Google Chrome
and to Chrome OS that is at the
heart of its security model.
Sandboxing is the concept that
all browser tabs, applications,
and web apps that you
deploy to your devices
are contained within
themselves, and they do not
have access to the OS and
to other applications.
This is a model that makes sure
that your applications cannot
access your OS, cannot
access your data,
and applications cannot
cross-talk to one another.
And site isolation,
on top of this,
keeps all the processes within
each browser tab separate.
Part of this methodology is what
keeps your Chrome OS device so
secure-- that even if you do
hit a malicious site, that it
only stays within
that one sandbox,
and is not able to affect other
areas of your Chrome device.
The Chrome Web Store is a very
popular Chrome marketplace
where you can download
extensions and get
various applications to
deploy to your users.
From an enterprise
management side,
you can push those
applications out to your users,
and users also have the ability
to manually install them.
Chrome Web Store applications
also have permissions that they
will effect on
your Chrome device,
and as an administrator, you
have the ability to block
permissions so certain
applications cannot access
certain areas of
the Chrome device,
such as maybe
blocking a USB port.
And finally, other
Chrome security measures
have been in place to disable
the install of extensions.
So extensions can only be
installed from Google's Chrome
Web Store, where
machine learning
and artificial
intelligence is used
to ensure those
applications deployed do not
contain any malware.
So management of Chrome devices
is a very popular method
to managing the various
policies on your device.
There's over 200 policies
available in the console.
And at this time, some of the
blacklisting and whitelisting
of extensions and applications
are widely used by enterprises
to pick and choose
applications that they
deploy in their
environment, whether it
be to users or to devices.
You also have the ability to
blacklist URLs and prevent
users from accessing
sites that you have
forbidden as an organization.
And finally, the
Password Alert Policy
is something that you can employ
to ensure that your users don't
use their corporate password
in noncorporate authorized
websites.
So this can ensure that their
corporate-owned passwords
do not become phished or
utilized in other areas outside
of the corporate environment.
So Android apps on Chromebooks
is an ever-growing environment
to deploy applications
on your Chrome devices.
Play Protect is
a proprietary way
that Google inspects the
applications within the Android
market.
And it scans and
removes applications
every single day
from the marketplace,
ensuring that you're
only deploying known,
good applications
to your environment.
And additionally,
as an Enterprise
feature as an
administrator, you can
build a curated
list of applications
that your users can
then choose to install.
And as an administrator,
you can also
choose to deny
applications, as well,
that shouldn't be installed.
And finally, each
individual application
may also have individual,
specific app policies
that you can apply
to that application
as well, whether it be
configuration or security
settings of the app itself.
Now, let's go over
some protection
against current threats and
how we can keep our users
and our data safe and secure.
So phishing is a very common
attack vector currently.
And phishing is the
concept that an email
is sent to a user that looks
legitimate, and is ultimately
getting them to click to
proceed to another website
or application or to
download software,
but it is not what the
user is actually expecting.
It is malicious software,
and it is ultimately
trying to either
exfiltrate their data,
or gain access to their systems.
So Google Safe
Browsing is one method
you can use to protect
yourself against these threats.
And at Google, we use what's
called a security keys,
but essentially, a second
form factor for your identity
can be another popular
method to protect
your users from phishing.
So even if they do willingly
give out their password,
the attacker won't have the
second form factor available.
And finally, if the
attack prevails,
implementing the
Password Alert Policy
so both users and
administrators can be aware
that a corporate
password has been
used on a site that isn't
owned or corporately managed.
So ransomware is a
little bit different.
It's designed to block
access to a computer system
until a sum of money is paid or
negotiations have been required
to gain access back to your
system to recover your data.
The Chromebook data model
is completely different,
and is really low on
device data footprint,
meaning there's no data
on a Chromebook, really,
to hold ransom, because the
data isn't on the device.
The Chrome OS is a
read-only operating system,
meaning that you can't install
software to affect the OS--
to infect it or install
software that may do this.
And finally, if ransomware
did exist for Chromebooks,
the verified boot
method would ensure
that it was not
able to be infected
and would not pass
verified boot methods.
And finally is Chromebooks
don't run traditional Windows
operating systems and
executables, making them
therefore a inhospitable
place to operate
within the ransomware
environment.
So other common attack vectors
are malicious applications.
And these could be
applications that ultimately
look to exfiltrate data
from your environment
or from your users.
And permission-based
blocking is a popular method
to ensure that these
applications don't have access
to your data.
So whether it's
blocking access to URLs
or blocking access to
portions of USB ports
and things of that
nature, you're
able to blacklist
or block permissions
to applications as well.
And Managed Google
Play also then lets
you just curate that list of
applications for your users
so your users aren't using
applications that haven't
been approved for by IT.
And finally, if
attacks do happen,
remember, we have the
sandboxing environment,
so any attack only happens
within that contained sandbox
or application
environment, and doesn't
affect the OS and
other applications
running on your
Chrome OS device.
So this is a very
common question
we get from enterprises as
they're new into Chrome OS--
is why Chromebooks don't require
antivirus or malware software.
So one is really,
again, is Chrome OS
was designed from the ground-up
as a secure operating system.
It is a read-only
operating system,
and applications
cannot be installed,
and they cannot modify the OS.,
therefore limiting the ability
of what antivirus software
would be able to check for.
Sandboxing isolates
applications so they can only
attack within their own
controlled environment.
It goes a little bit further
that any virus software
typically wants to be able
to scan entire systems,
and Chrome OS is not
a scannable system,
nor would have access to
scanners of other applications.
Verified boot is
typically another method
to prevent tampering of devices,
and if a device is tampered
with, it won't be
bootable, and the user
would have to wipe the device
in order to regain access to it,
and wiping any
data along with it.
And finally is there
is the ability,
as an administrator,
to curate and manage
your control list of
extensions and apps
to your Chrome devices, further
limiting the attack vector
and the applications that
will run in your environment.
So why are Chromebook
updates so effective?
I'd like to say it's because
one update does so many things.
The Chrome update is very
unique in the ability
that it updates your
firmware, your operating
system, and your
application with one update.
There's not separate updates
for patching applications,
or patching OS and
patching firmware.
The update happens
in the background,
it is seamless to the user,
and it is a 6-second reboot.
In fact, in many
cases, users don't
realize they've been updated.
And finally, there are ways
of managing the updates
through the
Administrative Console
so you can selectively
choose when updates
are delivered to
your users, and what
devices receive the updates.
So Chromebooks are really
a trusted business laptop
in environments to keeping
enterprises' data secure
as they move to the cloud.
And I'm going to be going
over a couple of customers
that are using Chrome in
their environment today.
So let's talk
about Duo Security.
Duo Security is
a digital company
focused on digital security
and trust compliance,
and they were looking
for a solution
for managing their data and
ensuring that it's secure
no matter where the
device is being used
or where the device is deployed.
So the real solution
that they were after
is that it's secure by
design, that they did not
have to layer on
third-party software
in order to manage
their devices.
And they also were able to get
a premium device experience
using Google Pixel hardware.
So it offers them--
in their words, it offered a
more effective endpoint control
and security.
The extensions and the Web
Store offered a wide array
of applications and
services that they
could deploy and manage.
And they also mentioned
that their premium devices,
such as a Google
Pixel, rival over
other competitors' devices.
And again, suitable for both
public-facing and internal use
cases.
So Charles Schwab is
another enterprise
that uses Chromebooks.
In addition to
Chrome OS customer,
they are a highly-regulated
environment
and a very
security-minded industry.
And one of the reasons that
they've chose the platform
is the settings that it
afforded to their administrators
in order to manage
their devices.
Chrome OS devices
and Chrome management
is a much more simplistic
way of managing endpoint
devices than traditional OSes.
It gives your administrators
more time and freedom
to do work that has higher
value than managing endpoints.
And of course, you can
always learn more by going
to cloud.google.com
/chromeenterprisesecurity
to learn more about
Chrome Enterprise.
And I want to thank
everyone for their time.
And if you'll just
please stay tuned,
we're going to be
going over the live Q&A
questions in just a moment.
Hi, everyone.
This is Jess Jagoda, and
I'm back with Cloud OnAir,
and we're going to be going
over some customer questions
that we've gotten from
our live audience.
So let me read the
first question back,
and then I'll go
into answering it.
So we have a question
that says, how
can customers
manage their updates
for their fleet
of Chrome devices?
Chromebooks can be managed
through the Chrome Enterprise
Administrative Console,
and Google updates
can be managed
through that console.
You're able to organize your
devices into a series of OUs
where, from there, you're able
to set policies that control
the updates, including
one, if you want,
choose to have
auto-updates, or choose
to not have auto-updates.
At Google, we call
that [? pinning. ?]
It is best practice to
remain [? on ?] auto-updates,
obviously, for best security
reasons and application
performance.
But as an administrator,
you do have the ability
to pause those updates as well.
There's also a number
of other settings
that allow you to
stagger the updates,
and also control,
as we mentioned,
the Dev, Beta, and
Stable channel,
as well, out to your fleet.
So there's lots of options to
controlling those updates out
to your environment.
Let me go to question number 2.
Are the security
benefits mentioned
in this deck available
on all Chrome devices
with all manufacturers?
It's a great question.
So Chrome OS is an
operating system
made by Google that is placed
on manufacturer hardware.
The manufacturer hardware
is negotiated with Google,
and contains all the proprietary
components like we mentioned--
the TPM module and that
tamper-proof-resistant
firmware--
inside of every
single Chrome device.
So whether you pick a
Chromebook or a Chromebox
or other Chrome form factors,
and hardware-independent.
Whether it is Google-made
hardware by another major OEM,
they all contain the same
underlying security benefits
that you receive, and
the operating system
is authored by Google
for all those devices.
So we have another
question here.
This question's
asking about G Suite.
So G Suite is a popular
series of applications,
including Email, Docs,
Sheets, and Calendar.
So it says, do I need
to be a G Suite customer
to get all the benefits
of Chrome Enterprise?
I would-- no, you do not
need to be a G Suite customer
to get the benefits
of Chrome enterprises.
We have lots of enterprises that
are on traditional productivity
applications, and are
not G Suite customers,
and are very successful
using Chrome OS.
They're able to deploy their
applications through the Cloud
Console and manage them
in a similar manner,
but simpler than their
traditional Windows devices.
And their applications can
also be deployed virtually
if there are dependencies
on Windows applications.
And that goes into
our next question,
asking, how will we run PC
applications on a Chromebook?
So PC applications, or
executable applications,
[? EACs, ?] do not run
natively on a Chromebook.
What organizations typically
do is virtualize applications
and deliver them to
their Chromebook.
So there's many popular
virtualization platforms.
Google has partnerships
with Citrix and VMware
to deliver those
virtual applications
onto your Chromebook,
but we work
with many other virtualization
platforms that are deployed
on the Chromebook as well.
So let me go on to
our next question.
So what are common
applications customers
deploy to their end users?
This is a very good
question, also very broad.
But there's a series
of applications
that I'd say are very common
to deploy on a Chromebook.
Some of the most popular
applications, I think,
are ones that
organizations use daily,
such as video conferencing
and teleconferencing
systems, such as WebEx and
Zoom and Google Hangouts.
But other applications, such
as Android applications,
are also very popular
to deploy, including
products by Cisco and Palo
Alto and other networking
applications that they may
use, and other productivity
software such as Microsoft
Office, as well as Google G
Suite.
And again, all
those applications
can be deployed through
the Management Console,
and are deployed through
the Cloud Console,
and then pushed to the devices.
So we have another
question here--
this is a little more
security-oriented--
about can we explain
a little bit more
about what ephemeral mode is?
So we mentioned, in the deck,
about a unique feature--
security feature--
called Ephemeral Mode.
Ephemeral Mode is
unique to Chrome OS,
and it gives it the ability
that every time a user
enters and exits their session,
that all the local data
within their profile is white.
So whether it's
downloaded content
that they put in their
Downloads folder,
cached data,
passwords-- anything
that may have been saved
during their user session
is wiped on the exit
of their session,
and every new session
created is a blank profile.
And no data is
stored or captured,
and is wiped clean every time.
This is, as we referred
to back in the deck,
keeping a low data footprint.
So it's a very popular
method for organizations
to employ Ephemeral
Mode, because they
can be ensured that there is no
data left behind on the device.
And our last question here
is a little bit on networking
and security tools.
What networking
and security tools
are available for Chromebooks?
Most of the major manufacturers
of networking applications
provide applications both in
the Web Store-- the Chrome Web
Store-- and on
the Android market
for networking applications.
So whether it's VPN applications
or proxy applications,
most of the major
manufacturers are
available within the
Google Web Store,
and on the Android Play Store.
I'd say the more popular
ones are obviously
Cisco and Palo Alto,
but many others
exist from the other
network providers as well.
So I think that wraps up
our questions that we've
gotten from our audience.
I just want to thank
everyone for tuning in,
and to please visit Cloud
OnAir to discover more content
from Google Cloud experts.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]